oh but okay I try to teach Charlie some
Russian end games maybe a little bit
[Music]
howdy hey man how's your evening going
good how are you doing today I'm great
I've been busy but thanks for being so
flexible of course anything for Daniel
I'm already you know I'm the tears are
coming and we're 30 seconds into our
conversation I might choke up actually
just don't be a little [ __ ] on your own
stream turn the webcam on a leash on my
own stream never ends we only were as we
you know chest dreams were never like
that so I was thinking obviously like a
lot of things that we could do I I am
aware of sort of the something that you
mentioned last time which is the order
of things you know how do you how do you
decide which moves to play first so
we're gonna tackle that a little bit I
was thinking we could start
traditionally with maybe one or two
warm-up games then go to sort of the
tutorial phase we'll do a couple of
different exercises and then maybe
finish with another couple of games how
does that sound to his honor his majesty
Charlie sounds wonderful to me just tell
me when to happen I played a little
recently that was that great wasn't
great
I hear 930 Rose and I only saw tumors
what the hell is this guy doing yeah I'm
not sure that's a weird play uh I see no
reason not to take that right I don't
see any reason I think that either he's
just developed his queen and nothing
else
he thinks he's intimidating do i yeah it
seems like a pretty worthless move do I
want to block with the knight of the
bishop go to develop bishop which one's
better here well think for the future
where do you want the night to be what's
the most active square for the night
well first of three and then getting a
walk around to eat five exactly so take
care of your future self something I
know you don't do in real life so
develop the bishop so that the knight
can go on to an active post also if you
were to develop the knight that bishop
would then be hard to develop true true
yeah I can he blocked okay he thinks
that the person who gives the first
check when's this game yeah so uh I'm
just gonna play this and you can tell me
if it was a good or bad move excellent
move
occupying the center stopping his night
from coming to c5 by the way which okay
now let's see if your four hundred-plus
exercises you've solved in a certain
theme have helped you
it's you're talking about the forks huh
I am talking put this pod yes that is
exactly what I'm talking about
I like that speed now you say his spawn
but I know which one you're yep very
good
that was that might've been the fastest
you've ever seen a 4k he thinks that I
don't know what he said I don't know if
he's thinking so what do you take with
you gonna take with the night first
right so in the trading Queens right
sure take with the night we'll talk
about this moment after the game this is
actually an instructive moment yeah and
that's why I would have taken to the
Queen you still have ways to extra house
night though you have to defend the
night how can you do it
um it's by pushing the pawn up right
exactly but one thing that we will talk
about actually today is some basic
endgame technique you're at the stage
where you don't need to shy away from
end games anymore you should be excited
travel yeah I don't hear any sounds of
excitement okay so we've got bigger fish
to fry now it seems that your your night
is lost but you actually have a really
really cool move here and I want you to
go ahead yet so I was the move I was
looking at was I see the Queen can get
pinned to that King pretty easily but I
don't have a way of getting the bishop
there so what I was looking at it's
bringing the Knight to g5 to threaten
Queen so that way he did have to retreat
the Queen which buys me a little extra
here with my knight that's I'll give
that moving a - go ahead I'll play it
then you can tell me better be a move
yeah so it was really like 7ed the top
move but the fact that you're seeing
ideas like 95 is still big okay your
idea worked like a charm because what do
you have now you can you can win the
game basically on the spot and whenever
he's counseled long you know we talked
about this months ago castling long by
definition makes the king weaker and
more susceptible to things like pins you
know stuff like that right but that
doesn't win the game it just wins me the
Queen's
I'm used to GM truck excuse me I'm sorry
it loses the game you only want to Queen
L moves in that barrel even gives me an
advantage is what you're saying light
slight advantage maybe you should offer
a draw
yeah honestly at this point this guy's
intimidated the [ __ ] out of me really
Oh God so now my nights no longer pin to
my queen so I can just get my night out
yeah exactly
and I found that people who capitalize
their names generally want you to be
more intimidated so we're not confident
in their play now don't you at the
knight move you wherever you want to
retreat it you can retreat it but do you
have a better idea I had a cool idea
that I thought would be checkmate but
his knight on a six stops it it'd be
Bishop f4 check that forces him to 8 a 8
and then I deliver the checkmate with my
knight yeah but I still like the move
Bishop f4 because even though you don't
checkmate him that still develops a
bishop with tempo yeah and when you said
cool move my ears perked up because you
do have actually a better mood than
retreating the night so first I would
clear the garden so to speak you know
there's some tension you want to release
it yes I want to go Bishop into Bishop
he had the rook and then eventually
midnight oh yeah so your tongue no
listening the knight on d5 but you
actually have something you can attack
that supersedes the fact that your
knight is attacked like imagine that
your knight was not attacked are you
talking about the Ford gone yeah exactly
oh you know that it rooks more valuable
than that night so okay well he just
hands you that on a golden platter
is there something I'm missing or is
that really just a [ __ ] move that is
just a [ __ ] I should move as far as I
know and so was that but well not that
he could have saved this room by the way
yeah okay he thought better of it and
Wow Jesus waft oh blistering start that
was nice that felt very easy so what was
this Evan had moved that was the only
thing that I think I didn't see so you
understand now why I perhaps would have
captured with the Queen just so as not
to allow the pin right but the seven
head move was so after he played c6 move
will your move 11 you played Knight g5
what I'm saying is his King on CA this
is King on CA
hypothetically if okay let's say you
didn't have a pawn on c4 how could you
have pinned his king like imagine that
pawn on c4 was on e4 could you have
pinned the c6 fun to the King and made
it a mobile yeah I just bring my queen
up to c2 right right but here's the
thing this is I think it's sometimes
referred to as a second order pin what
if you play Queen c2 anyway is that
absurd or does that actually have some
sense it makes you seem like an insane
person to me yeah I don't I don't see
what it did well that would just add to
your already existing assumption of me
but Queen c2 he takes your knight with
this pawn okay you can make the moves on
your board we don't need to do a
separate analysis board for that you can
just make the moves but then look at
that position very very closely what
move do you have do I just take care to
discover trying discover tech so you're
setting up a discovered check one and
two you're moving your queen away in one
fell swoop from the pin so if he doesn't
oblige and he almost certainly would had
then you can just extricate your night
from d5 that's [ __ ] huge yep that was
definitely a fivehead move I wouldn't
have seen right there sacking the knight
to win the Queen that's nice yeah it is
a very nice idea and it's not that
common to like setting up a discovered
check like that in indirect defense of
the night not too common so you know I
certainly don't hold it against you if
you failed me many times but you know
this is this is not one of them from the
a might I'll take the a- move with the
g5 yeah for a Russian grader that's
that's a pretty high mark you should be
it should be pretty happy with yourself
alright well that was too easy so up and
beckon yeah a more difficult opponent
seems to Oh Jon is a bomb again somebody
who already wants you to think he's cool
just from his account name the French
defense mm-hmm
so here I don't I don't know if we went
over this but I think it's just
developing night and then taking when he
takes pawn right yeah yeah exactly
you're playing the two Knights variation
which is a very reputable defense
well response to the French defense and
usually with full due respect to people
of your rating when they learn an
opening that's naughty 45 they only just
like learn one variation so if you will
go off the beaten path even a little bit
they're gonna lose their [ __ ] as he is
I'm sure he's losing his sherry now yeah
I wanted to flip his [ __ ] table over
Oh
that's happened a long time ago he's
picking up the pieces of his mouth okay
97 very passive development so all
opening principles apply do what you
would do normally okay um so now I need
to develop Bishop most active square but
that just delivers kind of a meaningless
check as I do I just want to breathe you
want to occupy the center you haven't
finished occupy in the center okay so I
want to bring my pawn up then yeah yeah
exactly so procrastinate grass sedation
is good at chess in some forms you want
to procrastinate the development of your
pieces until things are a little bit
better defined so you can actually
identify clear roles for your piece
bingo now clear role has been identified
for both of your bishops actually so
which one do you want to develop uh so
I'm thinking to develop my f bishop so I
just pin Knight to King and then the
bishop obviously on g5 for Knight to
Queen right excellent idea
you see what I'm saying how'd you played
this move you would have as you said the
meaning was check and he could have
blocked that check with the pawn now you
pin his Knight yeah and now I just take
with Knight and then I have both wits on
the attacking so it's a very nice
position look at how crams he is he has
the hard time developing his Bishop on
f8 so ok he attacks your Bishop okay and
in this position I don't remember if
we'd got over it is it best to hold the
pin by dropping it back and making him
push that up or do I just take the
knight here and ruin the structure you
don't ruin the structure because he
takes back with his Knights oh ah right
he's developed this money that is
literally the only purpose of developing
the nights at 7:00 Jochen of course
you've missed it so keep the pen have to
sneak that one in sorry well obviously
yeah it wouldn't be a Daniel lesson
unless there was a little bit of
[ __ ] on me exactly exactly
man he's he stuck between our up in a
hard place he's probably thinking about
ways to develop his bishop on that faith
and the way he should do that is by
moving his night away from e7 but you
know he's just panicking and introducing
more weaknesses so where would where
should the knight go I was looking at g5
then so this is again more advanced than
we've talked about thus far but if you
go Knight g5 he'll chase your night away
with h6 and that night will end up on
the rim on h3 so are you and I mentioned
this before you don't always have to
make an advancing move sometimes a
retreating move is actually the best in
the long run so okay just make a vanilla
garden-variety move keep the knight in
the center thank you I'll check it in
for the sub okay so I just want to bring
him back to well do I want to just put
him back on his original post at c3 yes
exactly that is exactly what we talked
about exactly what we talked about
mmm Daniel said he would play the Scotch
defense and he did sorry I was working
on some impression of some idiot yeah it
sounds about right
I think I know who that is I think I've
heard him before let's not discuss him
and bring down the quality of the
conversation we were having a good
conversation I don't want that person
mentioned yeah so Bishop d7 okay so he's
somehow developing his pieces Thank You
Shane for the gifts so again you don't
want to reinvent the wheel sometimes you
just want to keep developing yes and I
just want to console what's working like
the room yeah
but you see how much more harmonious
you're developing your pieces now like
it just your moves are flowing and it's
not as hard for you to come up with
these ideas anymore so let's start
identifying the weaknesses in his
position does he have any pawns that you
might want to pile up on a little bit
later and remember what a wheel on is a
weak pawn is opponent cannot be defended
by any other pawns only pieces look at
you six
exactly so can you devise a few methods
of putting pressure on that pawn or
perhaps attacking it what types of moves
name at least three moves
okay I see rook on e 1 to directly
attack it bringing which move that but
well right now Bishop to g5 okay retract
the Queen yeah
yeah that's decent you don't have to do
that you can keep the Bishop on c1 and
apply pressure on his e pawn so both
moves are valid whichever one you prefer
I'm just gonna go with the bishop
because that's typically how I play it I
know he's probably just gonna block with
Bishop yeah you'll trade bishops him
he'll be left with a bad bishop on d7 so
there's nothing wrong with what you did
also the queen is in the crosshairs of
what piece if you develop it properly
you just mentioned this move yeah éva
one of my rook bingo
and that Queen is now in the rooks sort
of x-ray which is never never a good
thing for your opponent
okay castles this way and now you can
actually exploit the position of his
queen
by by using this x-ray you can remember
that the e6 pawn is now immobilized it
cannot capture it cannot move so there's
a certain way you can apply pressure on
it that you have not have been able to
bingo
great okay nice nice and you chase his
night away introducing more sort of
discord ination among his ranks yeah
these are serious players are facing but
they're getting blown to smithereens the
nice thing is the moves seem more
natural now I don't have to think too
hard about the actual moves yeah I'm not
used to like I'm sometimes you find the
move before I just four okay so b5 Wow
interesting move that doesn't really
change anything right I still just want
to take that night he can't take my
bishop cuz I just take his bishop with
this pawn too right he's actually got a
creative idea if he'd take his knight he
takes the pawn with his Bishop attacking
your queen with his rook then if you
move your queen Bishop so I would just
be very calm here and pretend that
you're almost not attacking his Knight I
see I see so he's actually I don't know
if he's actually thought of this or
stumbled into it but you know forget
that you're attacking his Knight for a
second deal with the immediate threat
yeah just need to drop bishop exactly
but this has another benefit you
actually reinforce the pressure on that
a six month which is again goes to show
that not all retreating moves are bad
like you can't reason like oh the pieces
moving backwards so I'm making a
concession that's not at all huh chess
works you see yeah that was an injury I
wouldn't have even noticed that x-ray
since there's literally two pieces in
front of the Queen but yeah that would
be a cascade I'd take he'd take and then
it's just wide open I'm like Queen it's
a similar concept to what you could have
done the last game with Queen c2 these
like opening other files that look
closed but he's yeah he's not bad he's
coming up with some creative ideas but
his position is so okay the narrative
ski jinx strikes again
yeah this doesn't make any sense now I
just take with night he takes with night
I take night it with Brooke right
like the
not much to this no a blunder tonight
yeah John is not a bum but that's what
happens players are put under this
pressure and then they they crack like
it like a GM would take 30 moves before
he cracked this guy cracks immediately
and that's the beauty of playing active
moves that really is like clockwork bro
the second you were complement excuse me
baby no it's crazy it's the same with
GM's - that's the way okay so he really
is trying to push this pin on your queen
okay so I don't want to take that for
obvious reasons I just want to leave it
there it has two defenders now with the
rook there or three Knights also
attacking on that d5 right there right
but isn't the pin on your Queen a bit of
a headache
yes so just developing the Queen away
then yeah and how could you do it so
such that it's conducive to your
ultimate goal of putting pressure on
that epon yeah I just want to drop it
over here - e - exactly exactly and now
he might blunder his Bishop he might
take
he's probably knowing knowing from what
I know about him he might take on d5
with his Bishop but we'll see my my
ability to predict the future is only
limited to the moves of xqc but I guess
we'll see maybe he'll play b4
counter-attacking your knight he seems
to like these counter-attack moves now
we're all holding our breaths this is
cute this is nice
these these have been very instructive
games so far yeah and you've you've gone
to the next level we're not having the
same discussions we used to have about
the basics like the basics are you see
how it works you've subconsciously
internalized all of the basics so I
don't need to keep reminding you of
certain things which is great because
makes my job easier as well not that my
job was ever easy with it so don't like
you don't know no I understand yeah I'm
actually curious when you do those camps
what like fighter ratings are they are
we talking like superhumans or like you
know and some turbo nerds or something
different ranges uh I'm flying home
tomorrow actually I'm doing a camp in
about a week which is turbo no it's like
they are rated their masters and above
so all of the instructors are like top
hundred and fifty in the world because
you nobody below that could teach these
types of players so it's very exclusive
but I also teach I've taught for the
past five years of camp in person in
Atlanta which features ten groups and
the groups range from total beginners to
super advanced players master's that's
why I love these camps is you get to
interact with such a wide range of kids
and I enjoy different types of teaching
I love teaching super advanced players
it's incredibly fun you know it's almost
doesn't feel like work but I also really
enjoy teaching beginners and honing my
methods that's nice man that sounds real
nice and also just disciplining
disciplining the kids and being strict
so I love that well obviously yeah
bullying some kids I imagine has its
perks oh yeah so in this position here
is there any reason I don't just take
this bishop I'm no longer being pinned
I'm not in a threat of like a back rank
because my Queens also protecting d1
he's just wondering it he forgot to the
very typical mistake by the way it is
it's not television it's a different
classical type of mistake where he was
pinning your queen and he didn't ask
himself what the point was of your move
like he was just like Oh that pins gonna
exist for the rest of eternity but then
he didn't move his Bishop away so you're
up two pieces you can start collecting
the harvest but yeah the Kemp's are I
mean online it's it's it's a little bit
different you don't get that interaction
cuz we do it's just a chess game is just
like any camp we do sports you know we
do recreation activities it's not just
sit around a chess board all day oh
really okay I didn't know that I thought
it was just purely chess
well the one in Atlanta that I reference
is actually a live in camp so they
actually we stay on the campus of Emory
University and it's literally like any
other camp it's just that the main
activity you know you have math camps or
singing camps this is just chess camp so
if anybody among your chat isn't he you
know kids and they were thinking of
something for June 2021 I have just the
place for them someone named cosmic
equinox just had a little baby girl if
you want to go yell at the baby or
something oh that's that's one of my
favorite activities okay so this is a
great
example of you know mature Charlie being
okay with a queen straight well if you
want to avoid Charlie you can avoid it
yeah I mean I see a different move I was
just going to get a check over here on
East six even [ __ ] better yeah
that's an it I'm actually missed them
with intermediate move you actually
after he moves his king away you have a
truly five head sacrifice move in the
spirit of those games we looked at where
Bobby Fischer sacrificed his rook let's
see if you can find it you basically go
straight for the checkmate okay okay I
like I like these kind of big brain
schemes and it's it's an understandable
move look at this is King position I
think it's Oh hold on before before you
give me any more hints that's taking
pawn on b5 with night he takes with Paul
and I take with rook you're basically
right but instead of taking with a
knight can you can use sweeten the deal
for him because he might not take the
knight can you do the same thing with
check I take with the rook to deliver go
because the key here is not to use the
rook with it to attack the case to use
the Queen so you take with the rook
that's check tonight that would not be a
bad move but he could have
intermediately take taken your queen and
then you would not have been able to
execute that combination okay but you
found the idea and read it it's wrong
PvP moves if he is puts on his five
had-had and mousses King away okay now
you have all these sexiest move of all
time you actually have the sexy moves
now I'll give you one hint what would
happen if the rook was not there like if
the rook was absent or it was a ghost
yeah I mean I could just sweep in there
and take that pawn okay so that's all
I'm gonna say yes so this book that when
he moved that King what I looked at is
sending the rook up to b7 you're making
the same mistake you made in the last
move that move is not a check so he can
in turn take I dia you have to be the
same thing but you have to do it with
checks of what square by thinking about
it's b8 them yourself some goddamn
credit though you I mean this is
something you would not have even come
close to looking at ya antium oh [ __ ]
yeah I would
I'm upset I could have had that I was
looking at b8 initially but I know but
you got the ignorant b7 that's fine
you're winning you're completely winning
there as well you're up to pieces but
here you don't give them a chance to
take your queen so so the thing that you
might have not noticed is he can take
the rook with the king but you do what
do you do now alright so now I still
just want to take that pawn regards
equity and it's the lobster pincer mate
you cannot stop you yeah from delivering
checkmate on what's Square right there
on b7 bingo that is a beautiful [ __ ]
coming and it starts from Bishop 66 Jack
so you just put on the board ap you're
forced first number four move
combination yeah and I can't get back
rank because my knight is defending at
d1 and a great observation on top of it
exactly right I had to look at that when
I was looking at the silver that would
be something like a 1600 rated pleasures
to give you a context of ratings
somebody who's like seventeen eighteen
hundred would probably see this
combination in about a minute and they
might miss a back rank checkmate at the
end of it so that's what's called
calculation that's why calculation is so
hard you can go through the hard work of
seeing all this and then miss something
some stupid little detail some counter
play that invalidates all of this yeah
and this was just game yes beautifully
very very nice let's I'm gonna repeat
that for the sake of my audience let me
invite you to an analysis for we got to
celebrate this we got to pop the
champagne this is your first ever see
and you I'm sure you can tell the
significance of this but this is your
first ever like actual combination in a
game that you found on your own okay so
thanks for the great feature oh I don't
know that that idiot is that bum okay so
let me and there's actually a couple of
observations I want to make I know
you're eager to you know to keep the
momentum going so yeah so he played the
French defense and the idea of the
French defense by the way it's like who
would be these French people who would
would play such a moving I wouldn't put
it past them but it's actually a decent
opening and the idea is to basically put
this pawn on d5 and have it supported by
the e6 pawn right
instance so we're gonna do a little bit
of positional training here could you
identify in terms of piece placement or
potential piece development a drawback
of putting your pawns in this manner
what the bone does it hinder oh well I
don't see what development you hinder
you [ __ ] oh you hinder that I see it
the cc8 Bishop this is called the French
Bischoff actually times openings are
identified by the piece that they make
very hard to develop so yeah this Bishop
is now obstructed by the pawn so that's
the drawback of this open most openings
like this they have a good point and
they have a drawback and this is this
opening straw bag now this nice should
be developed to f6 the he clearly just
doesn't know what he's doing here and
there's one thing I wanted to mention
which is that if I were actually playing
with white I would potentially actually
just develop the Bishop to e2 okay going
for the permit I did and I want to
explain to you why because this is like
the next level of chess understanding or
maybe even do what you did against Iran
and develop the Bishop to d3 I'm gonna
show you a concept here which is exactly
what you could have used against the
Arab and you did just with slightly the
wrong order which is that I can expose
an attack on this d4 pawn right with his
knight in his queen mm-hmm and you can
either take with it with your bishop in
which case you'll be defending this pawn
or you could take with the knight a move
that looks like a blunder but if you
reach back into your memory and you
remember your game with the Arab you had
the exact same idea here because
actually you can win the game
what can white do in this position okay
so it's gonna be delivering a check to
win a piece right because that's the
open diagonal here right little about
the order yeah so because again see Rob
you [ __ ] up the order you got lucky
but you messed up the order so it's
going with the knight first right it's
taking knight on d4 and then delivering
the check at b5 and winning the Queen on
d4 right exactly exactly so can deliver
the check first he can take your bishop
with his knight right simultaneously
escape the tension against the night so
you take take check you check the king
the queen can come back we block the
check but then you just take the queen
of your best
so yeah this one's the game so partially
I would have developed a bishop for that
reason but on d3 it also basically just
its harmoniously placed and later on I'm
looking at a potential Greek gift
sacrifice so for example there might be
a scenario many moves down the line you
know back when red you know maybe maybe
a time when restaurants and bars are
open again when he castles and maybe
there is a time when he like moves his
night away from g6 and then that Bishop
could could basically aim at the pawn on
h7 so you see how I'm like making a move
that might only show its impact like ten
moves and down the line but that's like
true development now the problem of the
move like this should be five is that
the bishop stares at this knight on c6
right which looks like a good thing but
the issue is his night is already
reinforced by one night and by one pawn
so this pin is really not that affected
what he could have done here if he knew
what he was doing is just chase your
Bishop away and then chased it away
again then the bishop would have had to
go to b3 and now it's staring at a pawn
that's really really well defended by
his pieces like it's staring at this
point but this pawn is defended by three
of his pieces so this bishop isn't
really fulfilling as harmonious of a
role in the position as it perhaps could
be so does that kind of make sense
intuitively yeah that makes sense to me
and again I don't really like going for
those pins it just made the most sense
to me but I think I'm gonna start
looking more for what you just
demonstrated like looking a couple moves
down the line as opposed to just right
in the moment right exactly in Bishop e2
you might look at this thistle Lane
developing mode like that's just like
vanilla ice cream kind of move but
that's okay you're still you're still
preparing castles you don't always need
to conquer the world and you know put on
your Alexander the Great had with with
every move you know you can make a
couple of small big moves to make a
couple of big big big moves at the end
of the game you know it's not like I'm
developing most actively and and I'm
never retreating and those players don't
get very far in chess so now we need to
celebrate the combination I mean
everything else you did was perfect and
then this freaking move so I was gonna
suggest that you just take the Queen and
live with you two extra pieces rook
takes b5 check so what happens if a
takes b5 can you demonstrate for the for
the sake of the crowd yeah so that's
just coming in here yep
King forced thanks yeah exactly
Jack so he's got him of his name's he
moves it to a seven here you have to
modify your strategy a little bit so
what do you do yeah this is what I'm
just coming over here right this is
delivering the check on b7 bingo exactly
right he has to push he's pushed back to
a8 and yeah this is less elegant than
what happened again because you're
sacrificing the rook to two of his
pieces you can take the rook with two of
his pieces which to me sacrifices are
made more beautiful by the number of
pieces that can that can capture them
yeah oh I'll show you a one of the most
famous sacrifices of all time and you'll
see how beauty can be defined it just
sorry I interrupted what were you gonna
say
you said I like that you didn't
interrupt that was the whole statement I
just said yeah like what's so profound
that I need time to digest I like it I
mean I've never heard anybody say that
before that's it's consisted of consists
of three where I I'm trying to determine
the role of the word like in that
complex sense it's good it's a
combination combination yeah exactly you
sacrifice the word eyes but in the word
like so I was gonna show you one of the
most famous sacrifices of all time this
is one of the most famous moves of all
time and it's a little bit overrated by
as many of these games are because when
you go down in the weeds you see that
this move was not obligatory black had
many other wins in this position he only
just chose this move arbitrarily because
it was the most beautiful one so you
know in terms of discussions of chess
philosophy a lot of people think that a
truly beautiful move is one without
which you could not have won the game
you know what I'm saying it's the only
path to winning the game that adds a
certain elegance to a move if you're up
to Queens and you sacrifice one of them
well then big [ __ ] you know you could
have won in 50 other ways this game is
called the gold coin game it's called
the gold coin game and I'm pasting in
the position in which this move occurred
so congratulations you know your game is
mentioned in the same breath as the gold
coin game well eventually yeah that's
where I drew my inspiration from exactly
so this game was played in the year 1912
great year yep no ship sank in that year
yeah and it was played by sky named
Stefan Levitsky and Frank James Marshall
Marshall was one of the strongest
American players in of the early 20th
century and he was known as a very
strong attacking player so no surprise
that he created this move black to move
in this position so this will also
double as good tactical training for you
let's start with observations let's
unpack a little bit about what's going
on in this position anything that you
can tell me yeah so black is he's got
quite a few attack options here the what
I was looking at just initially off the
placement here since I've done so many
Forks I was looking at sending his queen
to e1 to get the rook out and then fork
the rook and then King on f3 with the
knight uh-huh so sending his Queens to
get the rook out so basically you want
to give this potential fork on f3 yeah
and then that also frees it up for a
back rank with our rook yes of some
concepts like these the problem is he's
got this pawn on g2 defending that
square oh the sacrifice like Queen to f3
which is actually very close to what
Marshall did but there's another concept
you should bear in my which is that your
opponent doesn't have to take sacrifice
pieces like if you put a piece on a
square it can be captured your opponent
can choose to capture it or you can
choose not to capture it here he would
choose to capture it
then you capture back he moves his king
up you take his Queen and you might be
like well I've won a pawn at the end of
this but what can he do now black or
white white so after her this entire
combination has been initiated and then
completed the problem is white has a
very nasty little move here I mean very
simple if you look at the whole board
there's a Hangu piece here yeah it's
just taking the night or taking the
night yeah yeah what I wasn't looking
for anything earth-shattering here so I
can let you try to find this move it's
an incredibly hard move to find because
it draws on so many tactical concepts
that maybe you're not entirely familiar
with yet and the story behind this game
which I don't think is actually true but
you know back then tournaments were
watched by a lot of people so there was
an auditorium and there were people in
the crowd and they threw gold coins at
Marshall after he played this move such
was the beauty of this movement such
goes the story I think it was [ __ ]
as most of these chess stories are but
it just gives you a sense of how much
people like this move now it sounds cute
all right
very cute it's it's so wholesome just
like the entire game of chess do you
want me to show you the move well let me
let me take a shot at it here I'll give
you a couple of guesses yeah I mean
you've been impressing me so far so
who's to say you won't find this move
too
so what came to mind I'll just go
through the thought process what I
looked at right away was taking pawn on
f2 with rook he takes with rook deliver
a check on a1 with Queen he blocks with
rook you deliver another check with the
knight and when a queen but I don't
think that works yeah I love that you
found that in in general the reason it
doesn't work and I actually had to think
about this is because you can start by
taking your queer and if you give the
idea of being you want to send the King
to h1 and then back rank made him well
he just takes her broke yeah
so doesn't quite do the trick but you're
definitely thinking in the right area of
the board obviously but it's even more
beautiful than that I'll give you a tiny
it's not a capture and it's not a check
that's also a maysa move so amazing it's
so subtle in its own way
is it stacking the rooks by sending the
rook on h3 to f3 that would be too slow
if I take your Queen then did you have a
follow-up in mind no it's just what I
initially looked at yeah that's how you
have to find these moves you know you
kind of look at crazy ideas and you can
threaten checkmate the problem of
threatening checkmate is it Telegraph's
the pass he has a move to stop the mate
and you can just go h3 and unfortunately
you'll let your left down a queen which
you've sacrificed so close again close
but no cigar it I think it definitely
has to start with that f2 pawn like an
attack on f2 yes yes yes yes it attacks
f2 among other things that it attacks it
does make contact with that one I mean
I'll sort of maybe guide you a little
but I won't tell you anything that will
really help you but if this have to pawn
were gone that's actually you've seen me
saying this a couple times it's a good
test if this F do pawn were gone what
would black be able to do I mean then we
could just get an attack right on the
right on the King like a that'd be an
easy way they're just getting a back
rank which I have to pawn was gone we
can descend the rooks down hey
exactly so you could send your Knight to
e2 and then you could send your rook to
f1 and deliver checkmate so in a sense
this pawn is like tactically pinned it's
not actually pinned it can it can
legally move but if it moves to let's
say g3 or e3 or whatever it's gone then
you can deliver this checkmate so you
can almost imagine that this pawn is is
is not making contact with any of the
squares that it's defending now it's
only something else what if the h2 pawn
were gone from the board
what would you be able to do then thanks
Ranger for the sub I'm not sure what you
could do that quickly
I mean obviously you could get the Queen
over onto the h-file but that would take
two moves it's made in 100 you can even
if you want on your board you could
protect you could like move the H bond
with your mouse away maybe that'll help
you visualize it but it's checkmate in
one move if the H bond are gone yeah
just just frickin flush it down the
toilet if it really yep it's made in one
and it's a move that you're from oh yeah
so it's just checking with the night if
the H pawns not there and that's called
Anastasia's mate but I don't know who
Anastasia was but that's a form of
Anastasia's made exactly but if you give
this check immediately then the King has
you know king h1 so you can combine
these two observations oh okay well
thank you uh oppressor paradox okay so
it's not a check but it I see so he just
takes the h2 pawn with the rook right
well that'd be like a barrel again
because then he takes and you lost the
vehicle with which you deliver the
checkmate everybody safe right here the
Queen thank you're trying to order beef
in an Indian restaurant like you can't
give this rook oh damn I'm not sure man
I don't see it so people are all of the
people in your child let me see how many
of yours you have they're all gonna
simultaneously 5,000
ninety-two orgasms right now we're about
to happen so I want everybody to prepare
their paper towels whatnot okay so you
know whatever devices people use to mop
up um all right I'll say no more about
that subject
Queen to g3 Queen to fricking g3 okay
but
let's take a moment of silence for this
move first of all now I've explained to
you already some of the ideas so you
should kind of be primed for this move
but essentially the idea is this if you
take the queen of the h-bomb and what do
you do then you just deliver the
checkmate on e - bingo if you take the
queen with the F on
then again you deliver the check on e2
up can you do the honors of pushing the
write down and then you're just taking
this bad boy exactly but to add insult
to injury White has yet another way to
capture the Queen he can capture it with
his own queen that's that's that's what
I saw I don't see how that well if you
capture the queen of the rook he
captures the rook and no longer does
black have a rook on the H file so the
king can simply escape any kind of check
right here block it in the intermediacy
goes 90 to check for the king of the
Queen King has to move away and again
black uses the concept of the two pins
he takes the Queen with his night with
check that's [ __ ] oh man that's big
brain okay same thing you cannot take
with the HP on your pins you cannot take
with the house pawn because of the
background that you have to move your
King away and to end the combination
black takes the rook and essentially
he's now up a rook in the piece White
has to recapture the rook ruining in the
pawn structure and black goes 92 he's up
at night and at the end of the day and
this is what makes it perhaps this is a
bit of a damper on the combination for a
grandmaster this position is resign
double black has succeeded in
simplifying the game and if you look at
the starting position black seemed to be
in trouble because his queen is hanging
in his rook was hanging so it's a way of
liquidating the game into a position
where you're simply a piece off Wow okay
yeah I didn't consider g3 at all I
thought once you take with the Queen
your only option was taking back with
the rook I did
even thing right over the check and fork
there's so many different elements to
this combination which is what makes it
really nice now the problem is and this
is what modern sort of chess scholars
have come up with is that you didn't
actually have to go Queen g3 it's like
that always that [ __ ] in the room who
has to shoot down whatever
accomplishments people are sharing so
those people came along and they they
took a look at a lot of the games that
were considered the most beautiful and
they basically concluded a lot of them
were overblown because if you simply
move your queen away from its attack
there's a problem why can't white take
the road thanks formally for the bids
you still deliver the check on e - he
only has one retreat square or to the g2
or h1 and then you can just deliver
another check there on e4 and that's
that's it's not is f3 yeah but it's
still a winning move right
not quite it's unclear because f3 and
the rook is defending that pawn so
you're down an exchange here so the
reality is you have a fork you've opened
up the possibility for a fork by
disrupting but White's pawn structure on
the Kings side ok ok so you're just
going there to f3 then bingo night after
we check it's acting the King attacking
the Queen then you take on g5 and you're
up a queen for a rope which is an
overwhelming advantage gotcha
ok so this is sorry that was a very
long-winded explanation but the move
Queen g3 is is really really famous so
to me like that's real beauty you're
putting the Queen on a square where it
can be captured by a million different
pieces and yet none of those captures
work for whatever reason so anyways I
think this is gonna be a nice segue into
sort of the instructional phase where I
actually want you to solve a certain set
of problems we're gonna use that
learning feature again on chess comm to
qualify the types of problems that you
solve into a particular category and the
reason I want to do it is to reinforce
this concept of the order in which to do
things this is gonna be experimental I
don't know if the problems that show up
are going to be exactly the type that
but only if your game for that if you
want to play more that's your you're
totally the boss here so no that sounds
fine to me what do you want what you
want to see me solve
so let me on my own stream go to your
stream so that I can watch you just give
me one second so if you navigate over to
whatever the puzzles are and you click
on I'm learning so I want you to do four
move checkmates
and advance checkmates or because and
the reason why is when you have several
moves to a checkmate you have to get the
order right so we'll see how these
problems look maybe they won't be and I
want you to also actually know this is
fine this is fine okay so yeah just run
with these then run release yeah so
let's begin
oh Anastasia's main actually yeah so
this is exactly what we just looked at
right so then the order hears no that's
not right
say what move are you gonna play rook
eight run you got the wrong order so so
if you can start with a check you want
to start with a check now why won't you
start with rook h3 the reason is when I
when a move you make sets a threat but
it's not a check right it's like
telegraphing a pass in basketball
somebody can take can can can get a
steal by defending against that
checkmate
what defends that though if I did go age
three to start what can he defend within
a single move several ways he can play
rook to e8 to defend that particular
square with his rook mm-hmm he can also
push up one of his pawns in order to
clear out one of a series of retreating
squares for his King either g6 and then
his King is gonna have a cheese 7 or f6
and his King is gonna have f7 gotcha in
general not all moves which are not a
check give your opponent a chance to
defend we saw for example in your
previous game remember when you had that
Queen on h6 and the pawn on f6 that was
an example of something that's not a
check and yet he couldn't defend against
me but that situation is a lot more rare
than a situation in which you actually
check them first okay well that makes
sense to me then yeah I guess maybe I
thought a little too deep into it nice
okay now this one is I suppose a similar
dressed of it is similar but different
type of mating pattern
so if I do rook b7 he only has one
retreat square which is a 8 I actually
can't do that it's still protected by
the exact on b2 so you have to look at
other other forms of checkmating thank
you at night so that it does it start
with the night at c6 okay he has to yep
you drive the King into the corner and
now it's time to find the checkmate
okay so then it's just that that okay I
see and what's the final move the
combination yep rook to say there's a
small delay when I'm watching your
stream yeah I forgot about that okay
that makes sense perfect perfect perfect
so again it starts with a check you
drive looking into the corner you made
it okay this one is we might have to
raise the rating of the this is all this
is Anna chose an amateur our weak sauce
right here those of 800 Jesus Daniel
listen that is much less than 800 I
don't know what who comes up with it oh
my goodness and they're making a really
good charlie yeah Olin let me let me
back out and change these you had me in
the weenie hut junior I really do this
again what do you want me to go let's
I'm gonna throw it up to 15 is there one
inch I would I would go from the other
end to I would go like a thousand to
1,500 let me be careful what you wish
for but I think that's good Oh perfect
oh yeah are you freaking serious yeah
that's a broad mm that's like a tough
one do they have any other mates other
than the scholars fate okay someone's
getting fired over this it's the only
mate that matters really they have like
two types of main two having a night in
the rook main and they have those
scholars mate it's like nobody is
invented a the other mates before okay
yes someone in my chat says it considers
for move mate mate on move four yeah
that's basically what this okay this one
is decent but still to easy for you so I
think the combinations
they take takes yeah this is a very good
one in avoiding tunnel vision this is
called Boden's checkmate
Boden's checkmate yeah named after a guy
named Samuel Bowden not that that
matters even not that creates an iota of
importance in your life but in case you
were planning for that information this
type of pattern name that's checkmate
okay yeah cuz the d7 is protected by the
rook right exactly so you and and this
is what you have to do you open you look
at pieces whose control of squares are
opened up by moving other paces exam
nicely done keep going okay
we might need to raise this up a notch
even further actually yeah this is just
Chuck mater after giving they're giving
you too many mates in one I made it once
I don't know why yeah we might have to
do no advance checkmates just checkmate
it's in four actually okay I mean that's
fine okay but this one is good actually
so maybe I'll I take it back this one is
a really good problem
tough tough stuff and what comes to mind
so the first thing I looked at was
pushing my f2 pawn up to f4 to free up
this file if he takes I take with rook
it's checked but he just blocks with the
night and I don't know yep good thank
you and the same by the way goes if you
give in a lot I see some people in your
shadow suggesting this move Queen f3
check seems to protect me but he blocks
it with his Knight so you have other
avenues you need to identify first and
foremost the mating squares like on
which squares could you actually deliver
the checkmate and then how do you get
your pieces there in a way that where
they cannot be essentially stopped okay
well so what I what I looked at now is I
don't think it would work because I'm
pretty sure you don't have to take it
but if I threw bishop on to age six to
get rid of that defender right there so
then if he does well no he stills Bishop
so that doesn't even work anyway right
he's it's two defenders if I did that
its III really Queen yeah he's got a lot
so you need to create a checkmating
threat right now like you have only one
chance right now before he gets the
reinforcements in and that's the sense
of urgency with which you should be
operating so you have to create a mate
threat what their next move
donar we finally this is the manual it I
can tell you the the piece that moves if
you want yeah it is a queen move so I
scared you off a little bit with my
saint queen ft but it is a queen mode
well the only place to even threaten the
choi i mean i can threaten it multiple
ways but the place to actually check is
only on f3 but that check he just blocks
with the knight is it bringing the queen
over to g4 and looking that way to punch
that even further this move is not a
check so i said there's two categories
there are usually it's a check but not
always so it is h5 and then taking on
that pawn at age seven you're missing
the mating square the mating squares f7
queen h5 threatens Queen f7 checkmate oh
I looked deeper I looked at g8 yeah
really really freaking deep think about
okay yeah and it's not over yet because
he has one defense okay now he doesn't
defend well what would will the
differentially just be bring out the
pollen yeah if you go down to moose on
the using that arrow button so yeah I
brought it back whoops yeah so if he
goes g6 this is a great exercise in
identifying how the position has changed
which new diagonals have opened up which
new squares have opened up for your
pieces this is another application of
Boden's made you can go Bishop h6 or
Queen h6 and both moves lead to
checkmate actually Exia so you see now
what what do you think sort of caused
the difficulty it was it looking a
little bit too deep not surveying enough
of the mating squares yeah I guess I
just wasn't thinking far enough maybe
would be the problem I'm not really sure
I think I'm looking too much for a move
that puts a check and maybe that's the
problem
I got you I got you well this next one
is really five head so yeah so things I
look at immediately is I can pin that
pawn to the king there on f2 by bringing
Queen to b6 I don't know what the
follow-up would be there
could also bring the rook over to g5 to
pin the G to pawn to the king
not bad ideas either of them the problem
is you're down a piece so you know you
need to rob a bank and you're trying to
to pick up a $10 bill off the floor you
need something extraordinary and this is
actually a form of Anastasia's mate you
can if you don't for not too familiar
with a pattern and this training also is
helping you learn common mating patterns
which is which is necessary to get to
the next level the first movie is
actually a check yeah so it's the e2
check them bingo and it's you saw
something very similar in that Marshall
game I showed you so this next move
after 92 check is what is the real five
head of yeah so this is just this yeah
animus sure I show me the move cuz
there's there's a little delay yeah yeah
nice let's do one or two more and then
we'll you know I'll Salvage you from
this torturous drama solving no these
are helpful man I actually really think
the puzzles here super helped mating the
mating puzzles I think is what you
really really need okay this one is it's
hard this one is because it involves
several tactical themes rolled up in one
okay well I think it starts by
delivering this check at b5 he blocks
with Bishop I take with Knight he no
guess he takes with Knight his Knights
still defending the d7 squaring he also
has the b8 Knight defending it as well
it's just really reinforced well if he
blocks with this Bishop you take with
the knight and then you give a
discovered check with your queen the
promise if you give Bishop e5 check he
blocks with his Knight
yes all right you need to identify in
these positions piece of it where is the
and I'm gonna be a little bit vague here
so I'll explain it in a moment where is
the sort of focus of the tension whereas
most of the tension contained on which
square which piece which piece do you
feel like is the most vulnerable from
your opponent's side well the tension
right now is on the e-file here you have
an x-ray on his King the bishop was
pinned to it
the bishop exactly the bishop on e6 is a
very thin veil between the Queen and the
king right so you should immediately
start thinking about okay so what is
defending that bishop on e6 only this
pawn but he can't take my knight if I
take his pawn with my knight say that
the f7 pawn if I take f7 pawn he has no
way all he takes with the King actually
kay extend that calculation Knight takes
f7 King takes f7 in your head what
happens then look it really ate that
position as if you're looking at a new
board oh oh then I can just come up and
take Bishop with Queen protected by
Bishop exactly right so you know this is
removing the defender essentially but
you follow this by identifying where the
tension on the board is at its highest
right like it's not just a random Pro I
see it
well my level this is like the
multiplication tables but there is a way
of logically reaching the solution you
see what I'm saying yeah yeah that makes
sense so I guess I just stopped right
after the King takes and I thought that
was just gonna be the end of it so you
do this sometimes and and I teach my
higher rated sit in something called a
15 second rule that applies to
variations that you calculate six seven
moves long but you can do the same thing
basically it says when you're about to
stop calculating and you're about to
abandon
you're about to abandon a variation and
think that it doesn't work you take 50
more seconds afterward to make sure that
you're not abandoning it too early I
know it's a little bit lame and
everything but I had trust me it really
really works let's do one last one and
then I'll swoop in
Oh perfect the recipe blue chocolate
let's see
oh my [ __ ] eye please don't tell me
I'm seeing this
that doesn't count [ __ ] oh I like
those Pogo man those are so instructive
I'm oh well this one you better see and
this is why the shadow is a game of
pattern recognition what made is this
what is it called
yeah anastasius made a station eight
yeah exactly
I think it's Anastasia's maybe it would
be embarrassing if I were wrong okay
that make me feel like such a [ __ ]
idiot
I know you're you're like repeating what
a GM said to you on the G on doesn't
know he's talking about he should be
fired alright that's good for now but if
you're if you get the hankering if you
get the Jones to solve alone which I
know you get basically every minute of
every waking moments if you check those
boxes what you really need to work on
this will help you get the order of
things right is dealing with checkmates
because with checkmates the margin of
error is very very low if you make a
wrong move in the wrong order
you give your opponent a chance to
defend against to me
[Music]
you
[Music]